foreign
[Music]
I cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
[Music]
unless we get our act together and
behave like grown-ups
I'm afraid many hundreds of my
colleagues perhaps 200 will be leaving
at the behest of their electorate
I've got the list here 45p tax cut gone
corporation tax cut gone 20p tax cut
gone two-year energy freeze gone they're
all gone so why is she still here
[Music]
foreign
I would prefer this government to be
judged on its appalling treatment of the
worst off and the poorest within our
society the reality is that inequality
in Britain is deeper than ever before
poverty homelessness hunger are
increasing amongst the poorest people
and the government has refused to say
whether it will even raise the Social
Security benefits in line with inflation
and there are big wage disputes going on
in all the major industries